ever wonder what it would feel like to
step into an oven
welcome to death valley california
temperatures here can climb to a
scorching 54 degrees celsius
which is as cozy as the internal
temperature of a steak
in death valley it's so hot you could
fry an egg without a stove
but
how soon would you get fried yourself
what would your days in the hottest
place on the planet be like
what could you do to survive this
intense heat
and what could happen to your body if
you weren't careful
[Music]
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you live in the hottest place
on earth
it's so hot you can barely breathe
this national park that stretches across
california and nevada might as well be
hell on earth
located 86 meters below sea level it's
the lowest point in north america
and the surrounding mountains trap the
superheated air like an oven
for five months of the year temperatures
hover around 48 degrees
you'd think that life there would be
unsustainable but
it turns out that death valley
isn't always dead
it comes to life in the spring as
colorful wildflowers bloom and the
temporary lakes fill the lowlands
and besides the tourists visiting the
park
around 500 people live there all the
time
so pack your bags you're moving to the
scorching hot desert to join them
life in death valley would be very
different from anything you may be used
to
not just because of the heat but because
it's quite a commute to
well anywhere
the nearest high school and shopping
center is an hour away
it's a two-hour drive to the closest
major city and there are no doctors
dentists or restaurants around
despite this or because of this
there's a tight community in death
valley
in the cow creek complex
residents of its 80 units share a gym a
playground and a library
and since they don't get many visitors
during the hottest times of the year
they end up spending a lot of time
together
though there isn't much of an
entertainment scene in death valley
there's a lot to see outdoors
i mean after all we're talking about a
national park
you could listen to the tiny pops and
pings of billions of salt crystals
bursting apart in the heat
maybe enjoy the view of the colored
hills thanks to the oxidation of natural
metal deposits in the mountains
you could swim in a water-filled cavern
and if you're lucky you could even catch
a devil's hole pupfish
a rare fish that can withstand the hot
water
life in death valley doesn't sound so
bad
except for
that
it would take some adjusting to the heat
when our body temperature reaches 41.7
degrees
it can become life-threatening
this is known as hyperthermia and it can
lead to deterioration of internal organs
and eventually death
in the climate extremes of your new home
you could easily heat up to the point of
hyperthermia
your best bet would be to take it slow
first don't forget the sunglasses as the
salt covered basin can be blinding under
the sunlight
make sure you always have sunscreen and
protective clothing and avoid staying
outside in the warmer hours usually from
4 to 5 30 pm
if you don't want to die of hypothermia
you should prepare before you even set
foot in the desert
your ability to survive in a hot climate
is largely determined by your body shape
and size
that's because heat is a byproduct of
cell metabolism
so larger animals with larger bodies and
more cells typically produce more heat
dropping a few kilos or pounds might be
a good idea to adjust faster
most people adapt to the heat after a
few weeks but it could take you a full
year to get fully adjusted
at this point you'd have a lower core
temperature and your blood vessels would
increase blood flow to your skin
you'd also start sweating more
not that this should be a problem
and once you start wearing a sweater at
27 degrees
you'd know you're officially acclimated
at least to the warm season
during the winter months the maximum
temperature is around 15 degrees celsius
during the day
and as low as -1 degree during the night
which makes me wonder
what would it be like to live in the
coldest place on earth
well that sounds like a story for
another
what if
[Music]